let's see number two first right some of
these are much easier than others some
take a bit more work some are a bit more
involved you can see that number two is
almost identical to number one the only
difference is a minus sign okay so to
help us get what this should be equal to
instead of this right this is not much
I'm just gonna write in a subtly
different way sine of alpha minus B huh
right so we call this one a sum that we
call this one a difference right so
these are some and difference identities
this difference I can write as a sum if
I want to I can write it as this some
degree with that there's not much of a
difference right but the reason why it's
useful is it because it lets me fit in
this into something already know I have
an identity for this right something
plus something I'm just gonna write it
out okay so I'm gonna get sine alpha
instead of cos beta I don't have a I
don't have B to there I have - video
right so alright cause off - beat up yep
see that and then I'm just gonna keep
going plus cos alpha off sign I don't
have a beat up I have a minus beta okay
now look at this it's just what more
like to do cos and sine we looked at
this a little while ago if they both as
functions have different kinds of
symmetry do you remember this okay
we called them all and even which ones
which which ones caused causes an even
function which means that f of X is
equal to F of minus X and an example of
that would be x squared is equal to what
would I say here minus X is quite see
that so cosine has this kind of symmetry
f of X is equal to F of minus X so that
means that this cos of minus beta is in
fact pause being up right now that's
cosine this is sine it has the other
kind of symmetry which we call all right
which means instead of this this is even
symmetry odd symmetry slaps a minus
there right so for instance - X cubed is
equal to minus X all cubed makes sense
so I can do this with sine sine of minus
beta easy in fact minus sine beta so I'm
just gonna drag the minus side all the
way out the front and I'm gonna write it
in the same order I had before see it
see where I got it from it's almost
exactly the same all you changes a minus
sign here which made a minus I 2 period
there yep okay
now I held your hand for that one and it
was an easy one okay for number three
it's not quite so straightforward this
is what I'm trying to do I'm going to
give you maybe five minutes to think
about this before I show you how I do it
I'm going to encourage you to think
about what I just did the tricks I
employed and what other tricks you're
still got in your toolbox that you
haven't used yet okay when you some of
my tricks in order to get it back two
things I already know we've got two
things on the board see if you can use
either of them right off you go here we
go I better jet through short periods
okay so here's the way of approaches the
definition of cosine is the complement
of sine if I have an angle like saying
call 11 degrees the way I work out its
complement is I say 90 minus that 19
minus that which gives me in this case
79 okay so 11 and 17 I are complements
I'm gonna do that here but it's algebra
so it's sign of what 90 degrees -
whatever that angle is right which
happens to be
veno okay now you've got to stay with me
I did say something with more work than
others right this one is definitely more
away from the previous one here I've got
some gravity I can expand right 90 minus
alpha minus be done okay
uh-huh he is the kicker right this is
the way I started pairing them but I
don't have to keep paying that way I
compare them like this and now I've got
identity number two do I not is identity
number two it just happens that my alpha
is not alpha nine minus alpha okay so
now I can just use this identity watch
sine of 90 minus alpha cos beta right
this is a minus so I should have a minus
in the middle - cause all new 90 minus
alpha and what's on the end sine beta
right
you're 11 you're 11 we're running out of
time we're not going to finish please
help me okay
I can now undo what I did before I
introduce compliments and now I'm going
to get rid of them right sign 90 minus
alpha cos alpha cos beat up close of 90
minus alpha sine minus sine alpha sine
beta done now when I change this to get
identity for right I'll be a bit cheap
right let me just put it in like this
okay when I put in cause on alpha minus
beta
I'll have cos alpha and I cooked my cos
of minus beta but I already know what
cos of minus beta will be it is just
going to be cos beta because it's an
even function okay it's even but when
you get to this part here this will
become sine alpha of sine sine alpha
times sine minus beta which is odd so
that minus sign in there is gonna come
out the front and cancel so you'll get a
plus in there okay so with the sine
identities the signs match right right
the sides match plus plus minus minus
but with cosine they flip around here we
go babe Thermage plus becomes a minus
minus becomes plus okay yeah we're gonna
do it together
High School Musical is ruin my life okay
thankfully I get to edit these all right
now